hey guys it's max with max tech and this
is now and today what are we doing yes
so I built my first PC when I was 9
years old with my oldest son Noah we're
starting him off even earlier so how old
are you six six years old so we're doing
a budget PC this is about $500 or just
under 500 something that is really good
setup if you're just getting started or
if you're on a low budget and this could
be capable of pretty decent 1080p gaming
so we have a 1080p monitor at home we're
gonna get him set up so we can go and
play some games together now in front of
us we have a series of parts that we
chose strategically to make this be
really cost-effective I have the full
parts list down below in the video
description and as we go on if you've
never built a PC this is gonna help you
out when I do some simple explanations
about certain parts and show you exactly
where to plug everything in in fact
Noah's gonna be doing this so let's
start out over here what is this thing
right here Noah I'm gonna go and start
cutting it open this is the PC case
there we go here help me take it off and
then the next part that's going to go
along with the case is this thing right
here this is a cheap LED strip I believe
it's red just a few bucks and it's gonna
give it a nice little accent to make it
look good the next part that we have are
these two sticks right here and this is
Ram along with that we have our hard
drive so this is actually an SSD that
means it's fast 250 gigabyte won and
this is where everything gets stored so
if it's in the computer that remembers
everything you did yeah kind of exactly
so that's called SSD and next we have
this box right here yeah go ahead
and carefully and be very careful with
it so this is the motherboard and this
little chip right here got it out of the
box already this is an Intel i3
processor yep hold it this way so they
can see it this is like the brain so
this is what does all the thinking and
then this is what cools the brain down
this fan this is the graphics card this
is what actually plays the game this is
what makes the game show up on the
screen on your monitor and makes it to
look nice so this is Nvidia 1650
graphics card it's on the entry-level
the performance is pretty decent for
1080p gaming and it should work well in
a budget system like this and then we
have one last piece over here so this is
the power supply this kind of makes
electricity it takes one kind of
electricity and makes it into different
kind of electricity so daddy so so every
different thing they need different
kinds of electricity yes if you give
this too much electricity it can break
so this is a power supply it gives the
right amount of electricity for all the
different parts cool
yeah let's build it so we're gonna start
by taking off just these side panels you
don't really have to do in this order
but we're gonna just open it up and I do
wanna let you guys know that we are
going to be doing a separate video about
the actual gaming performance of this
system we'll have a link down below and
also at the end of this video as well as
time cards if you want to skip around to
certain parts all right we're gonna set
the side panels off to the side now
we're gonna put in the CPU so that is
the brain flip all the way up yep okay
now now put the brain inside and then
put it back on exactly so you see this
triangle right here this triangle needs
to align with the triangle that's on
here there you go I think it dropped
right in perfect it does feel like it's
gonna break you're right a lot of people
actually scared when they're building
their first computer gram
I'll push a little bit but it does not
break yeah see that cover popped off
automatically now let's go ahead and
we're gonna put the cooler on we're
gonna put a small amount on here go
ahead and push it out very very slowly
goes up stop no that's actually perfect
right there we're gonna line up the
little holes on the side we sat down the
fan now go ahead and push right here
just push down on there nope on this
thing right here so that is what locks
it in push harder
so there you go that was easy right okay
so go ahead and plug this in so this is
how it gets electricity now we're gonna
go ahead and plug in the RAM just so you
guys can see how to do easier and so you
understand how to do it there are two
holes see these little holes right here
that's one those are two little screws
that are going there to hold the
motherboard inside the case so it's
actually better to put in the RAM
afterwards it'll make it easier to screw
in if you do that later but just for the
sake of seeing how it's done we're gonna
do it right now
push down yeah there you go and the next
one there we go next we're gonna get the
system is set up and install the
motherboard so do you see these little
holes right here on the motherboard that
is where we put screws in do you see
there's some other holes in here too but
what we have to figure out is which ones
line up this is called the i/o shield so
inputs and outputs that's what IO is do
you see how we have these circles right
here and these circles exactly so that's
exactly it's gonna be but we have to
actually put this inside the case first
gonna line it up right here and these
are little locks like little Springs
that are locks okay now go ahead and
push put your hand in here from the
bottom yep and push up there you go you
got it one finger okay well you're good
at it then now we are ready to put our
motherboard in slowly get it in and we
are going to push it all the way back
and line up those circles
so we have 6 we have 1 2 3 4 & 2 up
there these parts are really hard to
show on camera but you'll see where they
go so we're gonna do this one and then
we're gonna do with the other five so
now we're gonna go ahead and plug in the
fans so you see the spin right here what
this does is it sucks in air it helps
the air come in from the front from the
top and it blows the hot air out just
like you did before except this time
you're gonna plug in right there at the
top so now we are gonna get our SSD
ready the reason we won with one of
these is just like is it's cheaper than
the empty ones even though it's a little
bit more difficult so what we're gonna
do is we're gonna grab poured these
rubber pieces so these rubber pieces are
gonna allow us to connect it to the case
those special cutouts go ahead and put
it in here and it's gonna help for it
not to vibrate at all so what are we
gonna do now Noah now we're gonna put
this in and these make holes and then
put it into the big holes so you can
actually mount this and now push really
hard alright so now we got that in we
are gonna connect these cables right
here this parts hard to show on camera
but take your time look at the manual
and maybe get some help as well
now we're gonna plug in the SATA cable
since we plugged in USB right next to it
the other end we're gonna connect right
to the SSD all right man you ready for
the power supply yeah so we have to
unscrew these four screws and then this
little inside portion is gonna pop out
we're going to connect it here and then
put it back in and screw in these four
so go ahead alright there you go
nice and while we're at it go ahead and
unscrew this one yep so this is the
little cover where we're gonna put the
graphics card so do you see where it's
gonna go it's gonna plug right into this
very long slot these connectors but
before we do that we have to take off a
few of these covers the top will help
you
like that yeah yeah so these two parts
right here those need to go behind the
motherboard and this whole section right
here needs to pop and plug into here so
go ahead and line it up take your time
don't go too fast
there you go man good job
starting to put this little cover back
on we have to have the cover on first
before we screw other things on this
cable right here is going to connect at
the very top corner over there and that
other fat one it's going to go right
here actually it is on you got it in all
the way just doesn't make the clipping
sound good job i buy this crazy bunch of
cables we're gonna need a hook one up to
here and that's gonna use one of these
connectors right here see how is a
straight line and a little edge that
it's a corner so that has the same exact
one there and then we also have our
little LED lights so it's gonna glow red
all right we've got that push there you
guys much easier that's it we connected
pretty much everything yep
now we got to be careful not to touch
this glass or the plastic so don't get
it all dirty and go ahead and put the
filter on top that is cool I like how
they made that for a cheap case to have
filters at the top the front and the
bottom I like is very nice alright man
so go ahead and grab the cable now let's
get our monitor set up
alright you ready are you ready to press
the button that is the on button right
there the monitor is turning on do we
have hackintosh it's the hold on this
hard drive you catch it Josh hackintosh
it's it's for Mac you'll you'll figure
that out later alright as soon as you
see the screen turn on start hitting
that button a lot there you go hit it
there you go ok let's press down inter
setup
unplug it go around to the back and plug
it into another blue one back there
alright so we did that hit the little
reset button there that makes it turn on
and off alright so now as soon as you
see it there you go perfect oh look now
we have this next one we're gonna go
down which ones we're gonna use this up
so that what I just clicked on the one
that said SanDisk
that's the brand of the little thing we
plugged in that is gonna install windows
and the windows is gonna let us to be
able to download games go on the
internet watch your videos all that
stuff yeah so there we go go ahead and
grab this go next and install Fi alright
turn around to the camera so there we
have it
we're gonna look at that one alright so
we've selected our SSD we're gonna hit
new right here hit apply and ok there
you guys have it Noah Congrats on
building your first computer at age 6
this is gonna be his new gaming PC so
we're gonna have two systems set up next
to each other at home at this time I
have a bunch of Peters they're all that
work for work stuff nothing at home so
now we're gonna have a couple systems
set up over there so as you guys could
see this is fairly easy to do hopefully
all those steps kind of gave you an easy
explanation on what the different parts
are and how you can build a system very
easily and fairly quickly so if no one
can do it with a little bit of
assistance with this video you guys
should be able to do it as well Noah did
you like doing it yeah alright so if you
guys want to see how this system
performs make sure you guys subscribe
now we're gonna have a link as well in
the video description to that video so
you guys can go and check it out and see
how this $500 system can game so thank
you guys for watching this has been Max
and yeah and know what you look at look
that way so they can see you and we'll
see you guys in the next video daddy are
we gonna make another video